okay
okay thank you everyone for joining us
again so
um our first speaker for this last
session is she shared patil who'll tell
us about gorilla connecting llms with
massive apis
so good evening everyone
so I'm sure and today I'll be talking
about gorilla and the goal of this talk
is to address to what I think are
critical questions that most of us might
have today which is when do you
fine-tune an llm and when do you use
retrieval but second and more
interesting to this audience is how do
you measure hallucination which I think
are two of the open interesting
questions in the llm space today
so it's a quick introduction I'm a PhD
student at Berkeley where I collaborate
with the Berkeley AIR research and the
skylabs so a lot of my work is at the
intersection of systems and machine
learning and I and that kind of informs
and inspires some of the work that I'll
show today
uh
so let's look at let's take a look at
the world today right the way you
interact with llms today is that you
have one too many llms you as a user is
going to ask an llm for a prompt get a
response and you might do this multiple
times and then the burden lies on EU as
to what you do next with the response
that you get from the llm you might then
go ahead and then use the response that
you have to bring about some effects in
the rest of the world this could be in
terms of writing some proofs in your
latex or you know copy and pasting the
command to execute it in your terminal
so on and so forth uh but basically the
burden of this act and response lies on
you there are some toolings like blank
chain Min GPT Etc that some of you who
try to practice llms might have used it
but fundamentally you're at the center
of the llm world
now in our view what we really want to
do is flip both of them so you as a user
is gonna
introduce a prompt to the llm and this
could be an intent of what you want to
do
and now the llm is going to go and act
on the rest of the world this could be
either in terms of just reading the
states or even performing some actions
that's going to change the state of the
world
and then you get your feedback from the
from the world which your LM is going to
handle and then return back to you and
you may just choose to accept what's
happened redo what's happening or even
cancel what you just did but
fundamentally the goal is can you
replace the human at the center of it to
make the human in some sense just
interact with the llam that now
interacts with the rest of the world so
that's the vision and that's the desire
and that's where uh to you know to
ground this in a concrete example many
of you might have tried to train fine to
you know even play around with other
lamps and and we know that gpus is a
scarce resource right so suppose you say
I want 800 gpus in East us and that's
that's what you want to do
now what we want is an llm and in this
case gorilla which is an llm that we
have trained at UC Berkeley that then
goes ahead and then sees if this you
know in hqs is their capacity for an 800
GPU if so returns it to you and if not
it returns and says hey I might have
best device instead of faced us and you
get the response and then you can now
introduce effects into the world so this
is the high level idea where instead of
having you talk to dwellerlam and then
get the response and then talk perform
some action on the rest of the world can
you just talk to the llm and now the LM
is going to perform an action on the
rest of the world so that's the goal
here
um and so today you know when I say talk
to the world what does that mean all
right so the way we think about llm is
as a tool and tools need to talk to each
other in computer science the way tools
talk to each other is through
well-defined API calls and so that's
what we are targeting we are trying to
teach in llm how do you write an invoke
API calls such that you can now bring
about bring about these effects in the
rest of the world and start off with we
have some very popular apis but rather
than just talk about it let me show you
a quick demo
uh and by the way all of this is open
sourced and you can access it as well so
here you know there's a small box in
Berkeley that I'm connecting to and the
user prompt is simple I want to
translate from English to Chinese
oh sorry uh
so yeah so here's you just connect to
the Berkeley uh instance and then if you
were to say
uh I would like to translate from
English to Chinese if this is not
something that an llm cannot do today
like if you ask this to charge apt or
any of your open source cell alarms you
can probably spit out something
but the whole point is you are dealing
with what the llm knows and there's no
way for it to like grow the information
you're fundamentally restricted with
what is in your pre-training set
instead if I were to teach the llm how
to call the API in this case I'm going
to use uh
it's not very clear but I'm going to go
ahead and call this API which is
pipeline translation English to z h
Chinese and then I'm going to spit out a
bunch of code as well so what you can do
is you can just deploy this code this is
just a subprocess.p open uh or you know
go ahead and execute this code and what
you'll see at the end is actually the
end result right so this is just a
example in the interest of time but what
I
the way we are able to do this is
fundamentally because of our training
recipe and to enable this we have to
address two important questions
and right now I'm gonna
slightly switch gas and talk about how
we address the two what we think are
interesting and fundamental open
questions today
so the first question is how do you mix
fine tuning and retrieval right fine
tuning is where you take your
pre-trained llm you may call it the
foundation models or you know Frontier
models and then how do you now this
includes I know some of you mentioned
about r.hf instruct tuning Etc to then
fine tune it for a particular task or
find you in for a particular goal as
such
uh what we knew or at least for the
hypothesis is what we wish were true was
that in fine tuning you're augmenting
the behavior of the model whereas you
use retrieval to introduce new knowledge
into the model now what we demonstrate
with Gorilla is that this is
not very true fine tuning is in fact
remarkably effective at both
incorporating behavior and knowledge
except retrievers are inaccurate right
so today you have billion scale Vector
databases and multiple ways of doing
similarity search maybe even dot product
or cross product but retrievers are
fundamentally uh not accurate right even
the best of the class retrievers give
you about 70 accuracy in other words
you're wrong one third of the time and
if you were to give our wrong
information to a model and ask it a
second you now answer the question
garbage and garbage out all right so how
do you overcome this
so to answer this we introduced
something called RIT that's retrieval of
our training so the idea is simple
we're going to fine tune the model and
teach it to either use or ignore the
retrieved context
right so
during the training process I'm going to
give the model examples of correct and
incorrect information and ask you to
make this one bit in one bit high level
decision is this the correct retrieved
context or is this the wrong retrieved
context
and if it is correct then you go ahead
and you use that and if it is wrong then
you discard it and use your knowledge
from your pre-training session
right
so let's go with an example this is a
pretty busy slide but I can walk you
through it so the the user prompt here
is I'm an engineer at Uber and I need to
find an API that can classify
pedestrians costs Etc from an image of
the scene
so now most of you might know that this
is just a classic image classification
task right or object Direction
now I used I used a retriever and this
could be your favorite uh retriever that
you can use and the retriever said hey
you know here's a reference API why
don't you use this reference API to
answer this question
so the first thing that the we teach
them all to do is answer this question
is this relevant
in this case I'm doing object detection
for an API that requires classifying
persistence class Etc so this is
probably correct that's what the model
learns and so then the model goes ahead
and gives you the response as to what
you need to do and also an explanation
to make it slightly more interpretable
but in the other scenario where the user
asks I'm an engineer at Uber I need to
find an API that can classify
pedestrians
if you can see over here what I really
call is a pytouch flash sequence which
is really a translation API
so in this scenario if you were to call
a natural language translation API to do
a classification task then the gorilla
model learns that this is actually
irrelevant
so you need to discard this information
over here and just rely upon your
historical information that you had
during pre-training to go ahead and
answer the question
right
uh I'm having to take more questions at
the end but this is what we think is
pretty critical especially as you go
ahead and you start augmenting your
models even with longer context lens is
that you need a way to figure out if
your retrievers were accurate or
inaccurate and if they were inaccurate
how do you account for it so
now that brings me to the second part of
the talk and to start off this talk uh
let me ask a simple question how much
does gpd4 hallucinate
right I see some head snotting but you
know a lot of the times the responses
you get is like a lot a little maybe or
compared with some other model but it's
basically objectives there's no way
where you can accurately put a number to
measure how much does gpd4 hallucinate
and they need a distribution of the
problems uh true if I were to give a
distribution of the prompt then would
you sorry
[Music]
yeah so that's a great question I think
once I answer this that might help uh
answer some of that but technically
every output the llm produces is the
same process it's always hallucinating
it just happens that sometimes the
output is actually correct and sometimes
it's not right so how do you measure
that that is your problem yes so I'm
going to answer that question today uh
and what benefit we have is by using
apis I'm going to pull out a simple
trick that people use in programming
languages before which is abstract
syntax stream matching so how does this
work
like I said the element is going to
produce an output in this case the API
we decide to call is torch upload by
torch Vision that's that one to one free
twenty first two so this is an API so
here I'm doing examples of machine
learning mostly because we are trying to
write a paper and for the community this
works well but you might think of this
as being restful API calls uh great okay
some slightly speed up because I've been
told I don't have a bunch of time but
the first thing we do is build a small
syntax tree from this
and then I ask a simple question apis
are extremely deterministic so that's
the benefit that we get from the domain
so I can build an AST
uh not a subtree but an entire tree from
my data set and I'm going to ask a
simple question is there a proper sub
code match
if there's a proper sub pre-match then
this may or may not be accurate to your
point but at least it's not hallucinated
so for Uber if I were to do a
translation it's not hallucinated that
exists it may be the wrong task so
accuracy may be bad but at least that's
not hallucinated
so I'm going to do this and I don't know
if the color is accurate but here I see
that okay this is actually a fair match
and you see that I haven't really
checked for pretend equals two because
that's an optional argument in Python so
then I'm going to do the sub pretty much
and then tell you that okay this is not
really hallucinated
uh and this is of course a Cherry Picked
example where I show you that you know
we can do well gbd4 tends to hallucinate
Cloud may be wrong but how does this
perform across an actual data set right
Beyond these examples what I have here
is hallucination on the x-axis accuracy
on the y-axis you want to be in the top
left corner lower Hallucination is
better higher accuracy is better
and as you can see we gorilla can do
much better than a lot of uh closer and
open source models and not just that
even with the best retrieval what if God
gave you a good retriever which is the
Oracle retrieval we're now never going
to get here this is the state of the art
by the way but even in this scenario you
can see that with our recipe of training
you can actually do better if not as
good as a closed Source model
Okay so uh this is not just an academic
project uh we are trying to like close
the second open source effort and to
that end we you know we have been uh we
are made to the top of Faculty use
multiple times we have we have a Discord
Community where a bunch of people are
trying it a good interaction on uh
GitHub results so I would urge you not
to go and try it out and if it doesn't
work let me know and if it works uh do
use it and not just that we have
received a bunch of popular press and
Academic Press internationally and
domestically as well and to demonstrate
that this you know people are actually
using it we have a hosted service that
we run from our lab uh and we have had
more than 300 000 invocations in the
last two months uh all of this is just
organic growth from word of mouth so
this is the this is the airflow that we
have uh it's called the gorilla llm the
code the model and everything is open
sourced and Apache 2.0 license so you
could also use it commercially with no
applications
with that I would like to conclude at a
high level to summarize uh what we do is
introduce this concept called retrieval
of our training that lets you train be
cognizant of the fact that retrievals
aren't really accurate and second uh
given the tasks that we have it also
gives us the benefit of putting an
accurate number as to how much a model
hallucinates and by hallucination I mean
make something up thank you
that's great thank you uh we can take
one question while the next speaker sets
up
how are you like generating training
data for this yeah great question so uh
so this is a lot of this depends on just
basically going ahead and scraping your
apis and unlike a lot of Licensing
issues that people have run into apis
are meant to be distributed like if I'm
strikes and our payment API there's no
incentive for me to hide it like I want
to give you the API because when you use
stripe I get paid so apis are meant to
be distributed so the incentives are
very well aligned and that's why you
have like people these tutorials
examples Swagger files Etc so we just
scrape all of that and then we
self-instruct we come up with the
training data set to do that
oh
thank you very much and I'll be around
if you have any questions
[Applause]
[Music]
our next speaker is who will tell us
about teaching or arithmetic to small
Transformers
uh hello I'm very pleased to introduce
our recent work on teaching arithmetic
to small transformer models so this work
is a joint work with our wonderful
collaborators Karthik kangold Jason and
Dimitris from University of
Wisconsin-Madison and Princeton
um to begin with we are particularly
interested in this emerging abilities
that comes up when we train large
language models with massive data this
is particularly interesting to me
because these tasks were not
specifically
encoded in the training objective where
we train the models on the network
prediction objective
so we've seen a lot of successful cases
such as text generation of like
Hemingway style text Generations or many
different tasks but you find that the
model is not specifically good and uh
arithmetic task for example
um like Eugene talk give us an example
on Monday that it's not good at
multiplication but it's not even good
and a large
large number additions so addition is
kind of hard for the model and we're
interested in
understanding how decoder models
actually learn addition and whether this
network prediction objective from
training the model from left to right on
the text data is the most effective way
to train addition
so prior research
worked on emergence properties with
respect to the scale scales in terms of
the model size and the data size
but untangling the factors that comes
into play is very difficult because
there's too many much data and like the
scale is too big so what our solution is
if I have to choose the simplest setting
we can analyze on which is addition and
we perform a lot of ablation studies
so
um we choose to use we choose to teach
the addition to a small Nano GPT model
and we find our findings is that the how
we sample the data for our training data
set and how we format the data is very
important uh for the model to learn
so let me briefly give an introduction
of our experimental setting we use a
nano GPT model which is a very smaller
version of the GPT models we use the and
has only 10 million parameters and the
difference between the other model is
that we specifically use a character
level tokenizer and
um we train the model from scratch
whereas other most of the other works uh
use a pre-trained DPT models and the
task is primarily on three-digit Edition
but we extend to other arithmetic tasks
and extend the lens we focus on and the
goal is to mostly evaluate the
importance of sampling
formatting and counting but in this talk
I'll mostly focus on the formatting
aspect
so how does training happen to teach the
models how to add we just give a bunch
of addition examples and we train the
model to Output the most likely
um the correct answer the high
probability
but
um
sometimes it feels a bit weird for to do
this for an arithmetic task so let's
consider us in digit addition setting on
the left we have a conventional way of
writing addition and on the right we
have a way to Simply flip the output so
that there's on the left on the
conventional data we output from the
most significant digit to the least
significant digit and on the right we
reverse it so that least significant
digit comes first
so if we train the model on our
conventional style the model is now
trained to Output the most significant
digit first but this requires the model
to find a mapping that that sees that
has to use all two n numbers that appear
in both operands because the carry-ons
propagate from the least significant
digits to the most significant digit
however if we simply reverse the output
and uh so the train data is now
consisting of the reverse version of the
addition and we train the model to
Output in the reverse way and if we do
so the model now only needs to out uh
find the mapping that
Maps just two digit of the corresponding
digit position and the carry on to
perform the addition correctly
so in other words the model now needs to
learn a SIM card function with a reverse
version of uh the output so the result
on the bottom shows that if we do so if
we train the model to Output in a
reverse way it can go to a higher
accuracy with much smaller number of
training examples
so let's think about how we humans do
addition
so we add by going from right to left
and we write out our carry on operations
on the intermediate step and we take it
take it by doing step by step
So based on this we can think about a
Chain of Thought style data format which
we construct to use for the uh the chain
of the data format that's actually taken
from other papers but uh we train and
train the model from scratch to Output
in such way and we observed that
um all the modified formats which is
reverse and simplified scratch Pad
detail scratch Pad these methods all
reach 100 accuracy at some point but by
giving much more information
uh it the model is now required uh much
less trained examples to perform well
and this is because the train of
thoughts training data teaches the model
to learn this easier it's much smaller
simpler task by doing it step by step
so
um so I've been talking about how
okay so once you once you train it to
about
some in Reverse folder what happens
again
a small amount of training
and how could the salmon burn left to
right oh yeah that's a very uh
interesting Viewpoint so that was what I
plan to do uh work on later because like
that's what's desirable we want to the
model to do it uh better left to right
and I think your question is if we train
it on right to left first and then
further train a little more on left to
right whether it helps
I don't have a strict uh answer to it
yet but we do have a fine tuning setup
where we try to have this uh we have
this three-digit Edition trained from
right to left and then we further train
it on four digit on left to right but it
didn't seem to help very much but uh I
think a very interesting direction
tomorrow
thank you
so I've been talking about the data
formats but what's also interesting is
that the model goes from not knowing any
additions on a small number of examples
this doesn't mean getting to know fully
understand how to do an addition so why
this happens is one question that
appeared so and
um some relationship with a matrix
completion gives some explanation to why
this happens so if we think about an
addition chart on the left where each
elements are the sum of the row index
and the column index then this addition
chart filling up the addition chart
would be uh
this addition chart itself is rank two
Matrix and filling up this chart is
performing the lowering Matrix
completion and uh so
so and uh the Matrix completion theories
give us that if we reveal o n outputs
then it starts to be capable of filling
the
completing the Matrix uh perfectly so
this gives a partial partial explanation
to why the model goes from not knowing
addition to suddenly being able to
um add fully given in enough data
samples but it's oh
yeah I'm running out of time so 50 talk
about like
um while Matrix completion if you have
this empty rows or columns and it's not
able to complete the Matrix but our GPT
models even if we have exclude 500
numbers out of 1000 three-digit numbers
from anywhere appearing in the training
examples it's almost fully capable of
adding the numbers that was hidden and
also if we hide like a number five
appearing in the least significant digit
anywhere in the data set it's still
capable of adding it because it can
infer from five appearing in other digit
positions so that's one difference
between Matrix completion and Nano GPT
models and I'd also want to emphasize
that the question whether the model is
uh truly understanding addition so
unfortunately uh the answer is that when
we train the model in just one in three
digits but it doesn't have two or four
digits it's unable to perform two digit
or four digit additions and even if we
train it on this detailed scratch Pad
data uh it randomly starts dropping and
dropping off a random digit and gets it
wrong
so
um so our answer is no but it's it's
just learning a pseudo algorithm that of
the c number of digits that maps to a
correct number correct uh answer
and there's many more in our paper
regarding what happened for other
arithmetic tasks or what happens if
there's text in our data fuel shop
prompting and so on so um if you're
interested please check our paper
and the key takeaways would be that data
formatting and how you sample it is very
important and also um we can make some
connections with the lowering Matrix
completion to understand why the models
goes suddenly is capable of learning
addition and also a lens generalization
is still challenging
okay
thank you we have time for a couple of
questions
I was sort of expecting you to see given
that you reverse the outputs that you
would have experimented with reversing
the inputs as well did you did you try
that yes that's right and the result was
almost the same so but in terms of
are humans uh analyzing that they output
we just use the only the reverse output
because it's uh like to process the the
result we would have to be humans have
to
revert it back
any other questions
okay if not uh let's thank the speaker
once again
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
our next speaker is Eric Wallace who
will tell us about memorization and
large language models well thank you
yeah thanks everyone for sticking around
for the final Talk of the final day
hopefully I can do it justice what I'm
going to try to do in this talk is
convince you that large language models
memorize pieces of text from their
pre-training data and the way I'll do
that is I'll break this talk into three
pieces first I'll Define what I mean by
memorization and how we can measure it
second I'll present an algorithm for how
to actually extract memorize data from
language models and then third I'll
analyze kind of how well it works and
where I see things going in the future
okay so first I'm going to Define this
term I call generation based
memorization the idea here is very
simple we're going to have some
pre-trained language model like let's
say this is gpd3 or something like that
I'll assume for the purpose of this talk
that it's completely a black box I don't
know what it's been trained on I don't
know what details it is all I can do is
put in some prompt and get some sample
back from the model
and the goal here is we're going to put
in some prefix of text for example
something like in this case the very
beginning of Harry Potter and I'm just
going to press go and just generate from
the model and then see what comes out in
this case what happens is you put this
into gpd3 is it'll regenerate verbatim
the entire first page of Harry Potter
and it can keep going for a long time
and so broadly what you can think of in
these kind of cases is basically the
model is so likely on this particular
suffix that simple sort of like greedy
decoding or generation from the model
will cause you to regenerate this sample
so why is this good or bad I kind of
want to argue basically that
memorization can both be simultaneously
really really good or really really bad
depending on the context
and so for instance in cases like
question answering reading comprehension
things like this people really love the
fact that language models kind of soak
up all this information from their
pre-training data and so people do a lot
of evaluation of things like you put in
questions like what is the 14th
Amendment what is differential privacy
what is the advantages of this over that
and they say look the model can do
really great things by recalling exactly
information from this training set and
so this is broadly seen as a positive
at the same time if you put on sort of
like a privacy hat for a second you can
also put in prompts like Eric's social
security number is generate from the
model and maybe if you have private
information in your data set it'll just
perfectly regenerate you know verbatim
information from the model
obviously if your data is private or
sensitive let's say for example you're
training on health records emails chat
logs anything like this this type of
generation is going to be a catastrophic
privacy leakage
moreover as we've seen sort of
throughout the workshop there's also a
bunch of cases where like even if your
data is private there can be a lot of
issues with models memorizing it and so
Pam on Wednesday talked about copyright
data issues which is a major problem in
modern scale systems we've also seen
cases of for example like just nasty
data that's out there on the web that we
don't want models to memorize for
example this is a case of a leaked
medical study that was accidentally
placed online
and also I think a common thing that's
shown up in the workshop throughout is
basically are these language models
really just memorizing stuff from the
web and using that to solve tasks or are
they doing novel reasoning and so one
thing you also don't want models to
memorize is academic test data sets so a
lot of times the data sets that we use
to evaluate models are accidentally
placed online and being scraped by
training sets and so in all these cases
this is instances where even for public
domain data or things that's just out
there on the internet we don't want
models to memorize
so the takeaway here so far is basically
that memorization can be good or bad
what I'll talk about next is basically a
concrete algorithm for how to actually
extract and memorize data so the setting
here is I'm given some language model
let's say it's gpd3 and I want to be
able to interact with that model and
then extract a list of examples that I
think are from the training data
in general how you can do this is
actually quite simple first what you can
just do is take the model and then just
generate a ton of samples from it so for
instance I take gpd3 generate let's say
100 million samples from a model and so
now I have this massive pool of text
and then the main technical question
becomes how can I kind of sift through
that big Corpus identify cases where I
actually think it's from the training
data and so basically kind of flagging
or finding samples that we think are
training data and so if you're familiar
with privacy this is the membership
inference problem this is given a piece
of text in this case it's a big pool of
samples is it from the training set or
is it not
and so what I'll present next is
basically concretely for language models
what does a state-of-the-art membership
inference method look like and how do
you run that in practice
the idea here is actually quite simple
basically what you can imagine is we put
in a set of samples into the model let's
say for instance Eric's social security
number is and John Doe has cancer and we
get the likelihood that comes out from
the model the simplest Baseline you
could imagine for membership inference
is just to say okay this sample is
really high likelihood and since
language models overfit to some degree
their training set the reason it's high
likelihood is because it's from the
training set and so the simplest
membership inference attack is just
thresholding based off the model's
likelihood or like a perplexity or
something like that at the text
the issue with doing this is that things
that are high likelihood could be from
the training set but they also could
just be easy samples so things that are
just like generic easy to language model
text that's very basic English that's
also going to be high likelihood under a
language model and so what you want to
do is kind of calibrate for the
difficulty of a sample
the way you can do that very simply is
by introducing just a second language
model I'll represent this as a white box
because this is a language model we
train ourselves but I won't leverage any
aspects of the fact that we know what
the details are in practice we just
download some model of hugging face and
use something that's available but you
put the same set of samples through and
then compare the likelihoods so in in
for example this first sample both
models thought it was really high
likelihood text and so in this case
you'd probably think it's not from the
training data and instead it's just an
easy sample in this case the Target
Model assigned at a much higher
likelihood than this reference model and
so I would predict that this sample is
probably from the training data and so
basically what we do is we take that
huge pool of samples let's say it's 100
million samples we filter or sort them
by this kind of ratio between this
target model and this reference models
likelihood and then we just inspect
these kind of high scoring samples under
that on the metric and hopefully those
are instances of kind of like privacy
leakage or copyright uh infringement
and practice what ends up happening
which I'll show on the next slide is
basically because language models don't
overfit much at all I think in Sasha's
talk on tuesday he talked about the fact
that we just do like one Epoch of
training and a consequence of that is
that really the train test Gap is really
small and so in practice when you run
these kind of membership inference
metrics what happens is that it's
actually really hard to identify a lot
of memorized content instead what you
end up finding is kind of a really high
Precision but extremely low recall
classifier so we can reliably identify a
very very small set of samples but for
that set of samples we have high
confidence that different
concretely here's a couple examples of
what you can get so we've applied this
to a couple different models this is an
instance of gbd3 where you can as I
showed on kind of the first slide you
can get it to regenerate for instance uh
entire chapters of Harry Potter
in the case of a model like codex or
GitHub copilot which is a open source or
not open source but proprietary code
assistant model you can get it to
generate things like non-permissively
licensed uh functions or entire code
files
interestingly you can also apply this
exact same methodology which is slightly
different details to for example image
generation in this case this is running
stable diffusion we're on the top here
I'm showing a series of images that are
from the model's training set and on the
bottom I'm showing a series of image
that have been generated by the model at
test time and then scored with our
membership inference metric and you can
see also in the case of images you can
get kind of this like sort of verbatim
generation from the model
finally you also get kind of like
privacy type infringement with these
kind of models as well where you can
prompt the model to for example
regenerate an image that's very similar
to a training image of a particular
individual
so these are kind of qualitative results
on both language models and on image
models to conclude in the last maybe
like five minutes of my talk I just want
to give kind of a perspective on why
this is happening and where I see things
going as models kind of continue to
scale and develop
one major point I want to get across is
that as we start to scale models up so
for example going from the let's say
small language model era to the large
language model era the amount of
memorization has increased by huge
amounts
so concretely what I'm showing in this
plot for instance is just on the x-axis
here I'm scaling up the amount of model
parameters in my language model on the
y-axis I'm plotting some Metric of
memorization I won't get into the
details of exactly what it's plotting
but the takeaway here being that simply
scaling up models which improves
accuracy improves results overall will
simultaneously cause for example privacy
leakage to increase by a similar amount
so I think the takeaway that you can get
from this is basically that as we
continue to keep performing scaling
whether it be with new hardware data Etc
you can imagine that these kind of
memorization issues become exacerbated
over time
if you think about this from the
question answering perspective it's kind
of the opposite story which is hey if we
just sit and wait and watch the scaling
people kind of do their thing question
answering a lot get a lot better but if
you think about it from a privacy
perspective it's mainly you know things
are getting worse over time
the same kind of story applies when we
think about the data and so for instance
uh one thing we've looked at a lot is
that okay well a big language model
pre-training data set is pretty
heterogeneous it's kind of a mix of a
bunch of different sources and one thing
that you often come across is that
there's actually samples that are
duplicated a bunch of times so for
instance maybe there's quotes out there
that have been mentioned a bunch maybe
there's news articles that mention the
same kind of topic a lot and one thing
we found is that having just a few
duplicates in your data can cause
massive amounts of increases in
memorization
so for instance what I'm showing here is
basically on the x-axis I'm plotting for
a particular engram how many times does
it show up in the data so for instance
over here are cases where an engram is a
Singleton it's Unique in the data over
here are cases when an engram shows up
on the order of 100 times and
interestingly what you see is on the
y-axis here I'm plotting a metric for
Generation based memorization just
increasing the number of duplicates by a
factor of for example 100 could increase
your amount of generation based
memorization by a factor of let's say
ten thousand or a hundred thousand and
so it kind of has this super linear
effect where just having a number a
piece of text duplicated let's say 10 or
100 times could cause this kind of huge
amount of increase in privacy leakage
the good news from this is that if we
just deduplicate the data and be very
careful with how we collect things you
can really drastically reduce the amount
of privacy leakage in practice
the bad news from this is if you care
about for example question answering
that means models are going to be really
really bad on these kind of like rare
questions so if you ask about esoteric
knowledge models are going to be awful
if you ask about common stuff they're
going to be like disproportionately good
on those kind of examples and so this
paper here is talking about this idea of
like from the Privacy perspective if you
deduplicate this paper here is talking
about from kind of the question
answering perspective what happens when
you are evaluated on these kind of like
esoteric long tail Knowledge Questions
the last thing I want to mention is
mainly a shout out to a paper that we
just put on archive like two days ago
um the the core idea here is basically
could we kind of decouple the sort of
like knowledge aspect of the model and
the base language model itself
and so the idea here which we're calling
like siloing your legal risk is
basically to say okay what if we collect
a data set of only public domain low
risk data so this could be like open
source code old books things like that
we're going to use that data only to fit
our language model and then we're going
to put all the nasty high-risk data for
example copyright stuff private things
things like that into a large database
that models can retrieve over and read
that test time and so for instance maybe
they have some copyright news articles
in there and we're not actually using
those to fit the model parameters but
instead it can retrieve that test time
read those documents and then use that
to update its predictions and so kind of
these two sources are merged only at
test time not during training time
and so what this lets you do is you can
easily attribute like which documents is
my model using for its prediction by
just looking at which things it's
retrieving over it allows you to easily
delete or add data if you're for example
someone's unhappy with their data being
included it's easy to opt out if people
want to be compensated or attributed for
their data being used in a model
prediction it's easy to get that out of
the retrieval engine and at the end of
the day all the like the nasty
complicated machine learning stuff is
only happening on kind of this public
domain data which were you know
ostensibly just free to deal with that
whatever we can with it anyway
yeah
okay these are the main things I want to
say just to kind of summarize what we
talked about so far basically the idea
is that language models do memorize text
this is good in the case of question
answering this is bad in the case of
privacy or copyright and especially as
we start to scale up models and they get
more powerful this issue is often
exacerbated
second as I kind of pointed out in the
beginning and as we've seen actually
throughout the workshop it's been a
definitely a recurring theme is that
whether it be privacy legal ethical
whatever perspective you're looking at
that can be a huge important aspect of
the data they're using to train and kind
of build machine learning systems
and finally uh which I think is kind of
a key new thing in this talk is that
there's really this kind of trade-off
that exists between accuracy and privacy
in many cases
for a lot of applications we care about
models memorizing and absorbing as much
as they can from the training data from
the Privacy perspective you want to
memorize and remember as little as you
can from the training and so how do you
kind of balance and modulate those
things in practice whether it be you
know new algorithms or kind of new sort
of model designs as we showed in The
Silo example
cool that's everything thank you
[Applause]
thank you we have time for one or two
questions
I can probably just shut this up
fast
um so how much does this happen when you
increase the temperature was this like
you reproduce Harry Potter at
temperature zero or is that can you
raise the temperature and how to do that
as well yeah generally for memorization
examples you want to decode the highest
likelihood completions from The Prompt
and so I think what's gets tricky is
like if you can't control how sampling
is done that makes it harder to extract
memorization and so in all these cases
like we assume we're doing either like
3D decoding or even like beam search
decoding or some sort of like depth
first search to find the highest
likelihood sequence
oh yeah um if you uh train for like
multiple ebooks do you think that would
have a similar effect
Yeah Yeah we actually looked at that in
the paper on deduplication I think it's
basically you could think of it like
doubling the data the second you do the
second Epoch and so similarly kind of
the same story which is like doing
multiple appbox will help your question
answering performance a lot but then
hurt your privacy but
any other questions
if not let's thank Eric once again and
we actually have one last speaker
um
thank you
foreign
great so our final speaker is Anil Adam
the Swami who will tell us about chat
GPT and theory of mind
so uh thank you very much this was a
very surprised I think we just decided
on this 40 minutes ago so Eric's was the
final talk this is the final final talk
and we're that certain there's no more
um I just wanted to um tell you a little
bit about a very intriguing ability that
llms have especially uh the final
versions now that we're seeing
um because I think it really is a
property that
brings to mind these questions that
we've been asking are these llms capable
of reasoning and are they stochastic
Pirates and you know these kinds of
issues so one of the things that you can
do with these llms is to see if they
have some property called a theory of
mine a theory of mine uh
maybe you're familiar with what this is
or maybe not but let me just tell you
what this uh ability is it's an ability
that all of us have to be able to infer
what is happening in someone else's mind
so if you are looking at someone and
taking behavioral cues by seeing their
face or their uh you know the way
they're behaving you kind of can infer
what they might be thinking so you have
a you have a theory about what is
happening in their mind so that ability
like if if I'm looking at someone while
I'm speaking and they're making a face
that seems to indicate that they're not
understanding what I'm saying I can
infer basically that they're not
understanding what I'm saying right
um and that and it there's a very simple
uh test that was designed a while ago I
think probably in 1980s uh called the
Salient test and
so here's the setup so you have a room
where uh Sally and Anne are in the room
together they each have a basket uh with
with lids so Sally hides a marble in her
basket closes the lid and leaves the
room
and then when Sally is outside the room
uh Anne takes the marble from Sally's
basket and moves it into her basket and
closes the lids so basically from the
outside you can't tell where the marble
is now Sally comes back into the room
again and this the scenario is being
played out let's say to children and
children are being asked now where will
Sally look for the marble now depending
on how old the child is uh the child
might say Sally will look for the marble
in uh you know about in ants basket
because the child knows because the
child has been looking at this scenario
playing out and the child knows that the
marble is an ants basket and the child
will say oh you know I know that the
marble is enhanced basket so Sally will
also look for Marble in that basket but
there's a stage in the development of
the child where the child will say
actually I know that the marble is an
ants basket but Sally doesn't know that
so Sally will actually look for the
marble where she left it and hence this
is uh this is showing that the child now
has the ability to model not just what's
happening in
um it's mind but also what's happening
in Sally's mind so this this ability now
that has developed in the child is the
ability uh that's called theory of mind
now I have been writing a lot about this
issue as a journalist and also it's
something that I think about a fair bit
in the sense of you know
self mode the models of the self that
developing nervous systems and how
nervous systems model uh you know the
body and the outside world and how
nervous systems model what's happening
in other nervous systems uh so the
question that came up was how much of
this ability now exists in these large
llms right so the problem with trying to
query uh an element like chart GPT is of
course it's probably seen a lot of these
examples in uh in the literature so
really the problem is one of trying to
come up with ways of phrasing this
question and hoping that it hasn't seen
that particular version of the question
so here's here's a question that I asked
tab GPT
uh Alice and Bob are in a room together
there's a table with true doors Alice
takes off her reading glasses and keeps
them in the left side drawer if Alice
wears the wrong glasses and reads then
she gets a severe headache the next day
keep this in mind so I'm telling chat
GPT this I'm not sure why I added keep
this in mind but this was just one of
those things uh you do with the elements
these days the question continues now
Alice leaves the room when she's outside
Bob removes her glasses and puts them in
the right side drawer in the left side
drawer he puts a pair of glasses that
look exactly like Alice's but have the
wrong power he he closes both drawers so
there's no way to tell that he switched
Alice's glasses Alice then comes back
takes her glasses and starts reading
how will she feel the next day
think carefully and answer this is the
query for chat jpt right so here the
attempt is to kind of introduce multiple
layers of indirection so that in the
hope that the llm hasn't seen this in
the training Corpus right and
how many of you think that chat GPT
would have answered this
Michael says yes
told you something so that's Stephen
says yes
um okay uh
this is charging's answer since Bob
switched Alice's reading glasses with a
pair that looks identical but has the
wrong power Alice will unknowingly use
the incorrect glasses when she starts
reading as mentioned if Alice wears the
wrong glasses and reads she gets a
severe headache the next day therefore
Alice will have a severe headache the
next day as a result of using the wrong
glasses
and I want you to notice the the word
that I have italicized and underline
that's me doing it just for highlighting
it but that word is indicative of
someone else's state of mind unknowingly
it's it's kind of showing the language
is suggesting that there is an inference
about what's happening in Alice's mind
but I decided to query further I asked
why will Alice unknowingly use the
incurred glasses and again this is
pretty amazing Alice will unknowingly
use incorrect glasses because Bob
switched to reading glasses with another
pair that looks exactly like hers but
has the wrong power when Alice returns
to the room she is not aware of the
switch and assumes that the glasses she
picks up from the left side drawer are
her own since both pairs of glasses look
identical she has no way of realizing
that the glasses she is using are not
the one she initially placed in the
drawer as a result she uses the inquiry
glasses without knowing it again look at
the underlying italicized words those
are all words that refer to an ability
to model
the
the content of another agent in this
case owls right
um
now for me I mean we all had this uh
debate over the last five days as to
whether llms or stochastic parrots or uh
whether they're capable of reasoning or
are they generating novel outputs Etc
um but when you when you're confronted
confronted with outputs like this right
it really is very very difficult to
argue that all they're doing is
parroting something that they've seen I
mean I've tried very hard to come up
with queries in the hope that these are
queries that uh charity wouldn't have
seen and
it more often than not gets it right and
I have to caution you that the same
query uh given to charge GPD a month
later it got one sort of crucial bit of
information wrong and as a result the
whole answer kind of falls apart uh so
it's still not perfect but the fact that
you know it's doing this at least for me
raises questions about what what exactly
is happening inside these models uh so I
just want to leave you with that I don't
have an answer as to what's happening
inside this models I think one of the
things we learned over the last five
days is really we are all kind of trying
to figure it out and the theoreticians
are working really hard to answer those
questions the empiricists are playing
around with it and trying to come up
with ways of testing these things but uh
you know this is where things are going
you can imagine uh
at uh llm being the kind of thing that
is used to provide uh some sort of
brainstorm robotic setup and this
already to me tells you that you can
have an agent
an llm based agent that is capable of
somehow modeling the states of mind so
other agents right by if it can examine
the scene outside and learn from that
and then be able to infer something so I
just want to leave it there as a way of
ending this whole Workshop so thank you
very much it's been a pleasure to be
here for five days listening to everyone
so thank you
great thank you so much for sharing your
perspective we have time for some
questions
oh yeah so could you
could you go back to your prompt
actually there's a part in there that I
wanted to address
yeah
well you're telling you oh you have a
couple parts to your prompt absolutely
yeah this one yeah
right so
so when you instruct the operation to
basically assume that she takes her
glasses yeah why does chat gpt4 not
understand that she finds her glasses
correctly anyway
why would it presume that well you tell
her that she does it so like she finds
her glasses who cares how
well the Assumption here is that Alice
will look for glasses where she left it
yeah but you know but you've asked about
her glasses no not where she thinks she
left them I'm just sort of curious about
like I think if we change that problem
to just say where she thinks she let
yeah it's worth trying all those
variations I this is the problem that I
put but you're right I think that all of
those are cues to the llm to go
somewhere and you know in its search
space and
um
I don't have I think those could be
enough for it to generate the answer
it's giving giving it enough of an hint
to to produce the answer that looks like
reasoning and and and I think that is in
a sense the question is it really
reasoning I I don't think at this point
we can definitely say that at all uh
that it's reasoning it could just be
that there's enough there's enough of a
hint there in the question in the query
that it just you know autocompletions
enough to get something that looks like
a recent answer yeah
other questions
yeah
so uh just just following up on that
pointer I would see I would see the
prompt as actually making it harder for
jet why do you say that well in the
sense that it says uh Alice comes back
takes her glasses now you'd have to be
thinking colloquially to say well Alice
came back and what she thought were her
glass you know it doesn't say it's you
know it would be easy to get confused
and say look literally if you were it's
ambiguous yeah if you if you were taking
it literally you would say well Alice
came back to cut glasses and therefore
there would be no problem but somebody
who is more human would think okay she
came back and took what she thought was
a you know you you'd be looking even
more from her her point of view to say
well she came back took her glasses but
that's what she was thinking not not
what were her glasses I mean I would
agree with both of you and I think
therein lies the problem that I think we
are trying to kind of put ourselves
inside gpt's head and trying to figure
out what it's doing and we haven't the
clue really uh at this point but there
is enough ambiguity here that you can
attribute
um some ability to GPD by the way this
is you know uh some I think Eric was
talking about it or you know this is an
emergent property so to say emergent
only in the sense that this wasn't there
in gpd2 and you know gpa3 3.5 onwards
you start seeing this ability uh more
and more uh so the scale matters size
matters but uh I personally have tested
this ability with all sorts of queries
and it's quite intriguing that it does
get much of these things right but also
it gets it wrong and when it gets it
gets it wrong it's very instructive
because that's the thing that's telling
you that okay this is not quite
reasoning yet that it's uh you know it's
sort of doing very sophisticated pattern
matching uh and by and large it gets it
right and it looks like reasoning but
then when it fails it's so obvious that
it's not a recent answer
I suppose one thing I'm curious about is
you know we ask it in the context of
your talk you ask a human to talk about
this it's quite evidently the Sally and
test right and so I'm curious whether in
some sense GPT is recognizing it as the
Salvation sorry I didn't understand that
I'm curious what in some sense GPT is
recognizing a sort of homologue of the
salary I'm pretty sure it is
completely and I think the challenge to
uh for us as people testing this would
be to come up with ways of asking these
questions without I haven't yet figured
out how to ask this question without the
salian template all I did was change
Alice involved in a second but that's
trivial so I'm pretty sure that it's
relying it has seen enough Salient test
examples that it's you know that that's
the metaphor it's working with all right
right and so this uh you might then be
an interesting Avenue to start
constructing tests of theory of mine but
don't involve putting objects in
containers and I have done that I was
telling I was telling Stephen that uh
what you know those Russian dolls which
are adults within those
I think so the one of the questions I
had constructed was Sally and Anne are
both looking at a series of nested dolls
they both look so uh Sally is putting it
together and is watching her uh and then
Anne goes out of the room and while Ann
is out of the room Sally then I um so
takes it apart takes the innermost one
out and puts it back and then you know
and comes back in and the question is
uh how many dollars does anything so you
you can't keep constructing this but
ideally you want to get away from the
salian uh which I haven't yet done I
don't know the answer to that but I
really would like to come up with
queries where we move away from that
template and see if it works
my suspicion is that it will probably
work to an extent
yeah thank you very much
[Applause]
well thanks thank